[Laughter]
this is so
great lighting change
wow yeah we can put the light
anywhere and it doesn't awkward to be
really close to you no it does I
actually moved you I moved you back a
few feet before you got into the headset
you were like right here I don't know if
people can see this but this is
incredible the realism here is just
incredible where am I where are you Mark
where where where are we you're in
Austin right no I mean in this place
we're we're shrouded by Darkness with
ultra
realistic face and just feels like in
the same room this is really the most
incredible thing I've ever seen and
sorry to be in your personal space I
mean we have done J before yeah no I was
I was commenting to the team before that
even that I I feel like we've choked
each other from further distances than
it feels like we are right now I mean
this is just really incredible I don't
know how to describe with with words it
really feels
like it feels like we're in the same
room yeah feels like the
future this is truly truly incredible I
just wanted to take it in I'm still
getting used to it it's like it's you
it's really you but you're not here with
me right you're there wearing a headset
and I'm wearing a headset it's it's
really really incredible so what um can
you describe what it takes currently for
us to appear so photo realistic to each
other yeah so I mean for for background
we both did these scans for uh the
research project that that we have at
meta called codc avatars and the idea is
that instead of actually instead of our
avatars being cartoony um and instead of
actually transmitting a video what it
does is we've sort of scanned ourselves
and a lot of different
expressions and we've built a computer
model of sort of each of our faces and
and bodies and um the different
Expressions that we make and collap that
into a a codec that then when you have
the headset on your head it can it it
sees your face it sees your expression
and it can basically send um an encoded
version of what you're supposed to look
like over the wire so um so in addition
to being photorealistic it's also
actually much more bandwidth efficient
than transmitting a a full video or
espcially a 3D immersive video of of a
whole scene like this and it captures
everything like the flaws like to me the
subtleties of the human face like even
the flaws that's like that's all amazing
it makes you uh it makes it so much more
immersive it makes you realize that like
Perfection isn't the thing that leads to
immersion it's like the little subtle
flaws like freckles and like variations
in color and just yeah wrinkles all
stuff noses yeah asymmetry and just the
different like the corners of the eyes
like what your eyes do when you smile
all that kind of stuff
yeah eyes are are a huge part of it yeah
I mean there's all the studies that most
of communication even when people are
speaking is not actually the words that
they're saying right it's it's kind of
the expression and all that so and we
try to capture that with the kind of
classical um expressive Avatar system
that we have that's the kind of more
cartoon designed one you can you can
kind of put those kind of Expressions on
those faces as well but there there's
obviously a certain realism that comes
with delivering kind of this photo
realistic experience
that um I don't know I just think it's
really magical I this gets to kind of
the core of what the vision around
virtual and augmented reality is of like
delivering a sense of presence as if
you're there together no matter where
you actually are in the world and I mean
this this uh experience I think is a
good embodiment of that where it's like
I mean we're in two completely different
states halfway across the country and it
just like you know looks like you're
just sitting right in front of me it's
uh it's pretty wild yeah I mean I can't
it's I'm almost getting like it feels
like a
totally fundamentally new experience
like for me to have this kind of
conversations with loved ones it would
just change everything maybe just to
elaborate so the I went to Pittsburgh
and went through the whole scanning
procedure which has so much
incredible uh technology so software and
Hardware going on um but it is a lengthy
process so what's your vision for the
future of this uh in terms of making
this more accessible to people you know
it starts off with a small number of
people doing these um very detailed
scans right which is this that's the
version that you did and that I did and
you know before there are a lot of
people who who've done this kind of a
scan for we probably need to kind of
over collect Expressions um when we're
doing the scanning because we haven't
figured out how much we can reduce that
down to a really streamlined process um
and extrapolate from the the the scans
that have already been done but you know
the goal and we have a project that's
working on this already is just to do a
very quick scan with your cell phone
where you just take your phone kind of
wave it in front of your face for a
couple of minutes um you know say a few
sentences make a bunch of Expressions um
but overall have the whole process just
be two to three minutes and then produce
something that's of the quality of what
we have right now so I think that that's
one of the big challenges that remains
and right now we have the ability to do
the scans if you you know have hours to
sit for one and with today's technology
I mean you're using a a meta headset
that exists it's a product that's kind
of for sale now you can drive these with
that um but the production of of um
these scans in in a very efficient way
is one of the last pieces that we still
need to really nail and then obviously
there's all the experiences around it I
mean right now we're we're kind of
sitting in a dark room which um you know
is is you know familiar for for your
podcast but I think part of the the
vision for this over time is um is you
know not just having this be like a
video call I mean that's fine it's it's
cool or it feels like it's immersive but
um you know you can you can do a video
call on your phone the thing that you
can do in the metaverse that is
different from what you can do on a
phone is like doing stuff where you're
physically there together and and
participating and things together and we
could play games like this um we could
have meetings uh like this and and in
the future once you mix um once you get
mixed reality and augmented reality we
could have codec avatars like this and
go into a meeting and have some people
physically there and have some people
show up in this photo realistic form uh
superimposed on the on the physical
environment I think that stuff like that
is going to be super powerful so we got
to still build out all those kind of
applications and the use cases around it
but I don't know I think it's going to
be a pretty wild next few years around
this I mean I just I'm actually almost
at a loss of Wars this is just so
incredible this is truly incredible I I
hope that people like watching this can
get a glimpse of like how incredible it
is it really feels like we're in the
same room like there is that um I guess
there's an uncanny valley that seems to
have been crossed here like it looks
like you yeah I me there's still a bunch
of tuning that I think we'll want to do
where different people emote to
different extents right so I think one
of the big questions is you know like
when you smile how wide is your smile
and how wide do you want your smile to
be um and I think getting that to be
tuned on a per person basis is um is
going to be one of the things that we
that we're going to need to figure out
um you know it's like to what extent do
you want to give people control over
that um you know some people might try
to you know might might prefer a version
of themselves that's more emotive in
their Avatar than their actual faces you
know so for example you know I I always
get a lot of um critique and and
for um for for having like a relatively
stiff uh expression but you know I mean
I might I might feel pretty happy but
just make a pretty small smile so I mean
maybe you know for me I would I it's
actually you know it's like I'd want to
have my avatar really be able to better
Express um like how I'm feeling than
than what than how I can do physically
so I think that there's a question about
how you want to tune that but uh but
overall yeah I mean you we want to start
from the Baseline of capturing how
people actually emote and express
themselves and I I think the the initial
version of this is has been pretty
impressive and like you said um I do
think we're we're kind of beyond the The
Uncanny Valley here where it and it does
feel like you it doesn't feel it doesn't
feel weird or anything like that I mean
that's going to be the meme that the two
most monotone people are in in a
metaverse together but I think that
actually makes it more difficult like
the the the amazing thing here is that
the subtleties of the expression of the
eyes
you know people say I'm monotone and
emotionalist but I'm not it's just this
maybe my expression of emotion is more
subtle usually like with the eyes and
that's one of the things I've noticed is
just how expressive the subtle movement
of the corners of the eyes are in terms
of displaying happiness or boredom or
all that kind of stuff I am curious to
see just because I've never done one of
these before I've never done a podcast
as is one of these codec avatars um and
I'm curious to see what what how what
people think of it because you know one
of the issues that we've had in some of
the VR and and mixed reality work is it
tends to feel a lot more profound when
you're in it than the 2D videos
capturing the experience so I think that
this one because it's photorealistic um
may look kind of as amazing in 2D for
people watching it as it as it feels I
think to be in it um but we've certainly
had this this um this issue where a lot
of the other things just it's like you
feel the sense of immersion when you're
in it that that doesn't quite translate
to a 2d screen but I know I'm Cur I'm
curious to see to see what people think
yeah I'm curious to see if people could
see that um like my heart is actually
beating fast now this is super
interesting like the that such intimacy
of conversation could be achieved
remotely there's been you know I don't
do remote podcast for this reason and
this is like breaks all of that this
feels like just an incredible transition
to something else to the different kind
of communication breaks all barriers
like Geographic physical barriers um
what you mentioned do you have a sense
of timeline in terms of how many
difficult things have to be
solved um to make this more accessible
like scanning with a smartphone yeah I
mean I think we'll probably roll this
out progressively over time so it's not
going to be like we roll it out and one
day everyone has a codec Avatar um we
want to get more people scanned and into
the system and then we want to start uh
integrating it into each one of our apps
right making it so that you know I think
that for a lot of the work style things
productivity I think that this is going
to make a ton of sense in a lot of game
environments I mean this could be fine
but games tend to have their own style
right where you almost want to fit more
with the aesthetic style of the of the
game um but I think for doing meetings
and one of the things that we get a lot
of feedback on work rooms where you know
people are pretty Blown Away by the
experience and this feeling that you can
like be remote but feel like you're
physically there around a table with
people but but then you know we get some
feedback that people have a hard time
with the fact that the avatars are so
expressive and and and don't feel you
know as as realistic in that environment
so I think something like this um could
make a very big difference for those
remote meetings and especially with
Quest three coming out which is going to
be the first mainstream mixed reality
product right where you're really taking
digital um you know expressions of
either a person or or objects and
overlaying them on the physical world um
I think the ability to do kind of remote
meetings and and things like that where
you're like just remote hang sessions
with friends I I I think that's going to
be very exciting so yeah rolling it out
over the next over the next few years
it's not ready to be like a a a kind of
mainstream product yet but um we just
want to we'll keep tuning it and keep
getting more scans in there and keep you
know and kind of rolling it out into
more of the features but yeah I mean
definitely in the next in the next um
few years you'll be seeing a bunch more
experiences like this yeah I would love
to see some celebrities scanned and some
non-celebrities
uh I just just more people to experience
this I would love to see that this is
something I mean my mind is blow I'm
literally at a lost of words because
it's very difficult to just convey how
incredible this is how how like how I
feel the emotion how I feel the presence
how I feel like the subtleties of the
emotion in terms of like work meetings
or any kind of in terms of podcast this
is like this is awesome and I don't even
need to your arms or legs is that well
we got we got we got to get that
I mean that's that's its own okay
challenge um and and part of the
question is also so you have the scan
then it takes a certain amount of
compute to go drive that both for the
sensors on the headset and um and then
rendering it so one of the things that
we're working through is what is the
level of fidelity that is optimal right
you could do the full body in in kind of
a Kodak and that can be quite intensive
but um but one of the things that we're
we're thinking about is like all right
maybe you can kind of stitch a somewhat
lower Fidelity version of your body
would still still have the main kind of
the major movements um but uh but but
your face is really the thing that we
have the most resolution on right in
terms of being able to read and and
express emotions I mean like you said if
you move your you know eyebrows like a
millimeter I mean that really changes
the expression and what you're you're
emoting whereas you know I mean moving
your your arm like a an inch probably
doesn't matter quite as much so so yes I
think that we'll we do want to get all
of that into here and and that'll be
some of the work over the next period as
well